- BB Creams your podcast education has
been in the news this week with the
federal government announcing a new
schools funding plan but what are
teachers doing at a grassroots level to
innovate and to get the best out of
their students we asked cambers teachers
yesterday to comment about proposed
funding for schools going forward for
the next ten years Sharon from jeroboam
versus Tim we need smaller class sizes
because of the diversity of students
mental health concerns and family issues
teachers need to differentiate more so
than ever before teaching is all about
relationships as Sharon Carroll from
Walker said Gonski is wonderful smaller
classes are infinitely better individual
children can get more individual tuition
now a lot of money needs to be spent on
educating the teachers we're not having
enough of how to teach how to impart
knowledge without relying totally on
technology and the extra administrative
load on teachers is absolutely dreadful
and Tony from Belconnen says the same
thing administration for teachers grows
exponentially accountability and
reporting grows by the year we get less
time in front of our students
Eddie Wu is the headmaster teacher at
cherrybrook Technology High School in
Northwest Sydney he set up his own Wu
Tube channel that's right it's not
YouTube it's word tube it's been watched
by tens of thousands of students who
don't totally get maths or are more
interested in understanding how
mathematics worked and I was so moved by
Eddie Wu's story on the ABC on Monday
night on the Australian story but I
thought Canberra deserved to hear from
him directly and I'm really pleased to
say that Eddie Wu the head mathematics
teacher at cherrybrook Technology High
School is on the line good morning to
you mr. Wu
Tim it's lovely to be with you this
morning I was so taken any word by the
way you approached the enthusiasm of
teaching your students when did the idea
first come to you of videoing your
classes video in my classes was really
something of an accident in fact I would
love to take credit for being a well
thought out process but what happened
was that I had a single student who was
incredibly ill in my class he was
diagnosed with cancer and so he had to
spend weeks at a time several in a row
being away from school undergoing
treatment and of course recovery time
and I thought look this is an awful
situation for anyone let alone a 16 year
old boy and it's difficult to learn any
subjects when you're in school one day
out of school for the next month but
especially mathematics I think many
people had that experience where they've
tried to understand a concept but if
they're missing the pictures they just
can't fit it all together and many
people then just check out in
mathematics and say oh I gave up after
fractions or I gave up after they
started putting letters in the mix that
was just too much to me yeah and so
that's why I started video molesters so
that I could give them I could pass them
on to this boy and well it's not exactly
the same as being in the classroom at
least he had a sense of being
participating in the learning process at
the same time along with us so what
happened there Eddy was that more and
more students young high school students
wanting to understand math better heard
about some of these video this has gone
viral Eddy in fact there was a teacher
in the story I think at coba High School
and some of her students got onto it and
you now helping consult with other
teachers around Australia in helping
them to better teach maths to their
students
how important is it for teachers to talk
to each other about better learning
methods about better ways of teaching
students Tim it's so central to the
profession and I think that in fact I
you know some of the comments that you
were mentioning before from your
listeners about the difficulty is facing
us in terms of time I think one of the
primary ways that we feel that is that
teaching can be of
very isolating profession because in
many ways as a teacher you enter your
classroom you shut the door and you're
there with your students working as hard
as you can but often we lack the
opportunity to be able to speak and
connect with our fellow colleagues and
with our other educators and that's just
central I was very fortunate that when
my first teaching position I was
surrounded by a number of staff who were
incredibly experienced that taught
longer than I've been alive and they
were always really to answer a question
to provide you with advice but not
everyone has that opportunity you know
particularly as you mentioned coma areas
that are regional or remote don't have
access to do the same kinds of
professional development or even the
same kinds of learning communities that
other people in same metropolitan areas
do and that's how we develop as teachers
well do you know one of my listeners was
so impressed he's nominating you for
Australian of the Year and you know why
you know why I think it's a great idea
ready is that teachers are so important
to all of us I learned something new
every day but I'm past doing maths in
high school as you would understand I
host a breakfast radio program but you
are the future of the future of
Australia because you're creating that
inquisitor nervous and the learning
skills that young Australian boys and
girls need how do you how do you react
20 when people say that small class
sizes don't necessarily lead to better
outcomes for students what's your view
do you think smaller class sizes are
better for students in Australia this is
such a complicated question so I should
point out that I have you know my
classroom experience to speak from but
this is a very multifaceted issue I know
there are places in the world where
small class sizes are treated there are
other places where small class sizes are
not seen as a priority and there are
other areas that are focused on that
that funding goes to so I can definitely
say from my time teaching students this
is my pentia teaching I definitely view
the centrality of relationship rapport
yes my students as just it's just
foundational without that you don't have
anything in the classroom it's like
that's why a lot of people their memory
of say learning method
is that someone stood up in front of the
classroom they showed an explanation or
a concept on the blackboard and then
that they sat down and that was it and
if you understood it that was great but
if not then you were just kind of up the
creek without a paddle but learning
mathematics really is a lot more about
workshopping ideas and learning skills
together in a collaborative environment
and that requires the individual and
small-group attention of a teacher who
can understand exactly what the suit is
me now what point there are and what
they need to move forward it's very
difficult to do either of those things
when your classes are very very large so
I can definitely speak to the value of
that but I know it's not nearly greedy
the equation
yeah well said Eddie we've also had
teachers saying Tim the amount of
administrative work now and the
paperwork that goes with me as a teacher
within my school
you're a great user of time I think
you're a very good time manager as was
pointed out in the Australian story
where do you find the time to go and
plan the class then video and then go
home and edit that material I mean
you're a good user of your time what's
your advice to teachers who are time
poor here in Canberra look I would say
probably every teacher fifty time poor
one of the things that I experienced the
first moment that I said to the
classroom and started to interact with
students and do the work of a teacher
outside the classroom such as you know
writing reports preparing lessons
getting assessments already the work of
a teacher is never done it's not as
though you work say in a car factory and
there's the point where you put on the
doors and then you put in the seats and
then you make sure the whole thing
painted and then it goes out the factory
door and you're finished
that work doesn't happen in teachers
lives because you can always make that
lesson better you can always spend more
time tutoring those students
individually outside of class time so I
think my advice would probably be to
make sure that you've got the big things
first I mean you can fill up your life
as a teacher as any profession really
with a lot of the minutiae it's true
that there's a lot of admin in the life
of the teacher we benefit a lot from
that I mean I'll give you an example
once upon a time when we marks the role
in a you know New South Wales school
certainly we had a piece of paper we'd
keep that ticking along day by day and
then once we were done with the year
that piece of paper will go on a filing
cabinet and it'll be finished that you'd
never see it again
today when I walk into my classroom
rather marking about on a piece of paper
I'm going to have to log on I'm going to
have to record that electronically and
then adds a tiny moment into my
classroom but it gives me a tremendous
benefit because suddenly I see a profile
of my students not just you know in my
class and how they'll be going over time
but in every class they've been that day
over the course of the year and access
to that information helps me teach
better so I think making sure that I
don't lose the forest for the trees
getting the benefit out of those
administrative tasks like knowing your
students better but also ensuring that
look spending time with students and
advising them on the subjects they're
going to choose in the year ahead making
sure that I speak to parents and
communicate with them and make sure they
are on the same page with me those are
really big ticket items that if we get
them right first the rest will follow
how important is a parents and carers to
be across what their student child is
learning and that relationship between
parent teacher and and the student look
that the three-pointed relationship is
kind of a whole new Trinity of making
education work to be honest I see all
the time the both sides of the equation
where some parents are enabled to
provide incredible support to their
children and we see the difference that
makes and when students like that you
know it's not as though it's skills
their fate affects their education
impossible but it's so much more of a
challenge for these young people who
have going through an incredibly
challenging time in their life I think
we all remember the difficulties of
being a teenager trying to sort out who
on earth you are working out how to
navigate peer pressure and I think we
can all agree that today's teenagers
face that perhaps more than ever before
with social media and then to have all
of the academic concerns on top of that
the value of a parent being deeply and
frequently involved in a child's
education
you just can't overstate it I know as a
parent myself my children are three six
and eight and so my all
to our memory school and being able to
talk to them every day and to
communicate with their teachers and say
well how can I help how can I support
what areas do I need to be involved in
that process it's valuable beyond words
Thank You mr. Wu and mr. Wu - that's mr.
mas ter Roo - w TT ube comm Eddie we
thank you for being you Olga says on
Facebook Eddie whoo you are a legend and
one of our listeners says he's
definitely nominating you for Australian
of the Year and I think if you were to
be the Australian of the Year that would
be a big thumbs up to every teacher and
educator in Australia Eddie we thank you
for your time this morning to certify
thank you so much thank you Eddie whoo
head mathematics teacher at cherrybrook
Technology high school he doesn't just
teach a classroom his passion and love
for mathematics is self-evident and when
young students log on to his mr. woo
tube comm site they learn about
mathematics he's a real inspiration I
think we're very lucky to have spoken to
him on 2cc camera